il a coutume de dire que les quais de
loire c'est sa deuxième maison avec son
appareil en bandoulière christian bodin
à la passion de la photo animalière
mais pas seulement l'environnement
ligériens lui parle il suffit juste de
regarder par exemple là on a ce beau
graminées magnifique en contre-jour à
prendre en photo et puis on s'aperçoit
que eh bien il est complètement enlacé
par un liseron par une plante qui vient
s'entourer autour de sa tige et on a
vraiment des choses assez sympa pendant
photos depuis qu'il est devenu
photographe professionnel depuis
maintenant huit ans question baudin à
des centaines de milliers de photos à
son actif ancrée dans un territoire
qu'il aime tant ces photos il veut les
partager avec le public
d'où l'ouverture depuis quelques jours
seulement d'une galerie d'art ouverte
aux écrivains régionaux sur les murs ses
plus beaux clichés
voici celui qui le rend le plus heureux
cette maison bleue
j'ai mis trois mois pour la prendre en
photo à peu près trois mois
mais surtout je l' ai rêvé c'est à dire
que ça m'a réveillée une nuit à 3 heures
du matin en disant je veux cette image
je veux absolument montrer à
la mésange bleue en équilibre l'homme
veut être un animateur de territoire ses
photos et ses livres ne sont que des
prétextes pour créer du lien social un
pied-de-nez à l'époque probablement on a
besoin de se rapprocher de la nature
pour pour vivre et je trouve que cette
exposition elle est tout à fait ce que
je ressens lorsque je vais dans la
campagne
qu'est-ce qui vous émeut dans ses photos
justement eh bien je ce qui m'émeut
c'est surtout le grand calme que ça
représente
on retrouve beaucoup de sérénité du
calme du bo la loire et ses habitants à
l'honneur un vrai pari pour châteauneuf